AND THEIR BORDERS OUGHT TO B
SP
AAI
MUCH,IV.  CIVILIANS HAVE BEENS
T'LENGRE.ONE BRN
LL FACE THATD
MORE NOW FM  S ROAD FEW
TO TAKANYMORE.
>> Reporter: WHY DO YOU THIWORA
IT,  SS.CAN'T LEE E  HERE.
SO NEEDS T PEOPLE.'S HOPING THEO
ARTILLERY. BETTER FOR
E ROAD, HE
E THTHE SHELLS.
KIRTS OF
UNDER HEAV.LAST FEW DAYS
THIS MAN IS BEINEVWIHISO SHOUT .
THOSE WHO STAY OFF FROSIC RICIT
WATER AT ALL AND YAN
THEY'RE ACTUALLY COLLE
WATER.IT'S TIMFOR E TWO TOENTIRO
CAR.
LEAVING THE AGE SPOT A
THE FIRST T AND WAS A SECONDD TS
STEADY OLLERY
STBE.COMPLETELY WH
T,
E  WOKEN UP ANLYING
IN HER BNOIN.HE LIVING ROOMSHE A
WN DRAPES THATNGE
THIS IS HOW WE TRIED TSK  TELLS
THERE'S NOD FOR THEM
ORAND IL
R HOME
SHE UNDERSTANDS THATS
AS ONLY JUST
BEGUN AND IT'S GOIO GET MUCH
RS
VED UN AND N IAV ERYAY
OOS.THE  PEO
.HEY CAN STAY VER
COUPLE BY ALEXINFTEIR HOME.T THE
IT'SSH AT SHES RUSS ACTUALLWANTD
BLAMES AMERICA
THIS WAR
PLEASEON'T TELIST  W WORLD, ALE
N UNCO VIEW IN S OF EASTEAINEMA
THE RE COMPLEX.E EVAC
ANYONEWHICAL K AO E  HIS HEL